alright what's up this is the killer for
new battle League and I'll be your host
Donnie narco aka the walking drug lab
aka mr. splash put my drink on your
bitch's ass and won't even tip the glass
you feel me battle back is the street
fight you got someone right in your face
trying to tell you apart I don't know if
I should slap you like a [ __ ] or punch
your face like a man cuz I keep
switching from open palm to a fist like
a white boy sticking your head actual
geez
you ain't kill none stop it's awesome
just cuz you look like Hugh Johnson
doesn't mean you're ill son got some
creative Asian jokes at least you knew I
was Korean as far as I'm concerned
that's culturally sensitive my battle
rap standard that audience reaction it's
like heroin so what do you do
I mean besides appropriate black culture
for your livelihood oh she bodied you
not tonight say whenever I battle I'm
gonna get the [ __ ] box and you won't
get the Asian bar cuz that's what the
audience wants to hear
delete your account what you going to do
you ready Venus your crunchy granola I
can tell by your pungent aroma
we got [ __ ] once pregnant prostitutes
[Music]
if I did that would you be satisfied by
minimal well notice off white rapper he
realized after - OH
that's why I walked around dados bodies
entire family look right back
right so Luke got it got it hi that was
great
you